الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن ان التحقيقات بشان
اطلاق النار على المحتجزين الثلاثه في غزه
كشفت عن وجودهم في مبنى قريب كتبوا على
جدرانه استغاثات باللغه العبريه لكن
الترجيحات تشير الى مكوثهم به
لفتره ونشر الجيش صورا لما قال انه المنزل
الذي مكث فيه المحتجزون في
غزه معنا من تل بيب مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس ماخر المعلومات المتوفره عن
ذلك والتطورات
الاخرى عفوا عثمان لو تكرر السؤال لو سمحت
نعم كان هناك خبر عن اكتشافهم المكان الذي
كان فيه الاسرى الذين قتلوا الاسرى
الاسرائيليين وكتبوا عبارات استغاثه وما
الى ذلك سالتك لو كانت هناك معلومات عن عن
هذه القصه بالتح حديد اضافه الى التطورات
الاخرى في الساعات
الماضيه ن نعم عثمان هم يقصدون بطبيعه
الحال الاسرى الاسرائيليين الثلاثه الذي
قتلهم الجيش الاسرائيلي في الايام الماضيه
واعلن عن ذلك واعترف في ذلك يوم الجمعه
الفائت حيث ان هؤلاء الاسرى الثلاثه كتبوا
على جدران المنزل الذي احتجزوا فيه في
المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع ز ببقايا الطعام
عباره اس او اس عباره الانقاذ الدوليه
المعروفه وكتبوا باللغه العبريه مخطوف
انقذونا لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي بحسب
التحقيقات الاوليه لم يتعامل مع هذه
الاستغاثه بشكل جدي حقيقه عثمان وكان
واضحا حتى من التحقيقات الاوليه للجيش
الاسرائيلي بان ثمه اخفاق في عمليه
التعامل مع الاسرى الذين كانوا في هذا هذا
المنزل لا سما وان التحقيقات الاوليه
اشارت الى انهم خرجوا رافعي الايدي
وكانوا بدون لباسهم العلوي لكي يؤكدوا على
ان انهم لا يحملون اي متفجرات وكانوا
يستغيثون ويقولون للجنود الاسرائيليين
بانهم مخطوفين لكن الجنود الاسرائيليين لم
يقبلوا هذا ال هذه النداءات وبالتالي احد
الجنود فتح النيران عليهم و ايه باعتبارهم
انهم مسلحين فلسطينيين يحاولون التخفي على
هذا النحو من اجل تنفيذ عمليه ضد الجنود
الاسرائيليين وهذا كان اخفاق كبيرا يوضح
الى حد كبير ان هؤلاء الجنود اعطوا اوامر
بالقتل بقتل كل من يشاهدونه على ال على
الميدان او في ميدان المعركه وبالتالي
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعتبر ذلك كارثه كبيره
وكذلك المستوى السياسي في اسرائيل الذي
اعتبر ان هذا الامر كان بمثابه خطا
استراتيجي فادح في التعامل مع تعليمات
اطلاق النار لكن واضح بان هنالك غياب لهذه
التعليمات بل ان التعليمات عثمان هي قتل
كل من هو في الميدان وبالتالي وقع هذا
الخطا الفادح حتى ان ال الاسرى الثلاثه
الذين خرجوا من هذا المنزل كانوا يتحدثون
باللغه العبريه وكانوا يطلبون النجده لكن
الجنود لم يصدقونهم واطلقوا النيران صوبهم
هذا التحقيق ايضا يشير الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي دا عن انه اعطي الاوامر بال
بالقتل عثمان هذا يدلل على ان هنالك مشكله
كبيره حتى في وصول الجيش الاسرائيلي
لهؤلاء الاسرى وانقاذهم باي عمليه عسكريه